- If you constantly try to, you know,
to reach perfection at everything,
you're not going to reach it,
but you're going to get close.
If all I ever did was
win or lose at a game,
I don't really look at my life
has a lot of significance.
- He's a professional
baseball outfielder playing
for the New York Mets.
He's a former professional
American football player
who played three seasons in the NFL.
He was selected by the Denver
Broncos in the first round
of the 2010 NFL draft.
He's Tim Tebow, and here's my take
on his Top 10 Rules For Success.
Rule number nine is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always as you're watching
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below,
put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well
and when you write it
down it's much more likely
to stick with you as well.
Enjoy.
(swooshing)
(lively music)
- Why Baseball?
- When I was four, five, six
years old it was my first love,
this first thing I fell in love with
and I thought most of my life
I thought I was going to pursue
baseball as a profession.
Second hardest decision of my life.
I remember sitting on the
edge of my bed crying over it,
deciding what I was going to do,
and I ended up choosing football
and I don't regret that.
But, I do believe in pursuing passions
and what's on your heart,
and this is something
that I'm passionate about.
- What's it say about you
that you're even given the
opportunity as a 29-year-old man
who hadn't played baseball in a decade?
- There's certain things
in life that we love,
and we have chances to pursue 'em.
But a lot of the time
the fear of the unknown,
the fear of failure gets in the way.
I don't want that fear to creep in,
I don't want the unknown to creep in.
I want to be someone that I pursue
whatever is on my heart
with everything I have
and if I fall flat on my
face, then guess what?
I'mma get right back up.
- I've read that you're a farce.
I've read that you're a joke.
I've read that you're an embarrassment.
Not only to yourself, but
to the game of baseball.
- The first thing is I'm so thankful
that I don't have to read it,
I don't have to listen to it.
I don't have to live the rollercoaster
that the rest of the
world lives of my life.
I don't care what they write about me.
They've written a lot of things
over the last 15 years about me.
Some good, some not good,
some just 'cause they want to sell papers.
I don't necessarily care.
At the end of the day, I
want to pursue my passion
because I believe when you're
pursuing what's on your heart,
when you're pursuing
what you're convicted by,
then I don't have to live with the regret
10, 15, 20 years from
now looking back saying,
what if, what if I would have tried that?
Where it's a success is
if I give my all to it.
If I get to live out that
dream every single day,
whether that's in Single-A,
Double-A, Triple-A,
or it's in the big leagues.
Because joy doesn't come from success.
Joy comes from knowing your design,
and being able to pursue
that every single day,
and knowing that I get
to live out a dream.
(cheering)
(applause)
(intense music)
- [Sportscaster] Here comes Tebow!
He's got the first down,
he's got the touchdown!
He's got, it!
(announcer laughing)
(crowd cheering)
- When someone watches me do something
I say that's how it's supposed to be done,
and that's how we have to
teach it, just like that.
Because if you do something to the level
of success like that, then
that's going to carry over
into every aspect of your life.
If you constantly try to reach
perfection at everything,
you're not going to reach it,
but you're going to get close.
And that means you're going
to get close to excellence
and that's what we're all striving for.
(dramatic music)
- [Sportscaster] Certainly
the game not out of reach
but the Broncos offense is going to have
to get something going.
- [Sportscaster] This is
what you want in Denver,
so you're going to get
a look at Tim Tebow.
He's going to have to spark this offense.
(dramatic music)
- [Sportscaster] Tebow's
going to run this football.
Tebow inside the 10.
Tebow inside the five!
Tebow's got a Denver touchdown!
(crowd cheering)
At least you got a little emotion
from the Broncos' offense.
- You know, now I don't watch TV too much.
You know, it's hard,
'cause most of the time
I watch a lot of ESPN, but not anymore.
Honestly, you know, try to stay focused
and stay focused, and set little
goals for myself every day.
Get a little bit better.
Learn one new thing.
Improve in one way every
day when I step out here.
When you set all those little
goals and you keep hitting 'em
then you're constantly
going to keep getting better
and not worry about everything else.
Just let that take care of itself
and worry about what I can control.
- [Sportscaster] Five in the
secondary, on 2nd and 20.
Here comes Odrick.
There goes Starkes, and there goes Tebow!
On the fly!
(dramatic music)
(crowd cheering)
Tebow!
- [Sportscaster] This is
better than any jailbreak
you will ever see.
- I think for me, and playing sports,
it's not being focused on
winning or losing a game.
Because, yeah, you want to be the best.
You want to try to win Super Bowls
or make it to the big
leagues and all these things.
But you want to, at the end of the day,
be more than just the sport
you're trying to play.
You want to transcend that sport.
If all you do, if all I ever
did was win or lose at a game,
I don't really look at my
life as a lot of significance.
But if I can transcend that
sport to inspire people,
to put a smile on people's faces,
to encourage people, to make a difference,
to change one person's life
or a million people's lives
then I would consider that
significance and meaning.
The goal is not to be famous.
The goal is not to have
money in your bank account.
The goal is not to have what
the world defines as success.
The goal is to change lives.
(intense music)
- [Sportscaster] From the other side
Langford can't get him, he's
already sacked him twice.
And there's a touchdown reception!
(triumphant music)
- When you believe in yourself
that you're doing the right thing
and you're giving it your all,
you have to block out the criticism.
You have to block out the naysayers.
And, you know, a lot of
times people will say
let it go in one ear and out the other.
And I just think don't
even let it go in one ear.
Don't even listen to it.
Don't even go on social
media, don't read it.
Don't watch the TV.
And for me it's just, you know,
stay focused on what your goal is
and don't let the naysayers
sway you from your goal.
(dramatic music)
- [Sportscaster] Fells.
- [Sportscaster] To the pylon!
It's a touchdown!
- [Sportscaster] Tebow, quarterback draw.
Tebow's going to be in the end zone!
- For me it's, you know,
when a door opens, that's exciting.
When a door closes, you
look for the next one
and you handle every
opportunity as best you can.
You treasure the opportunities
when you have 'em,
and when they close then you
look forward to the next thing.
And you stay patient,
but you stay passionate
about whatever it is that your dream is
and you push forward and
continue to be your best
at anything you set your mind to.
(dramatic music)
(crowd cheering)
- [Sportscaster] Tebow keeps it.
Tebow to the 30 and out of bounds.
Over the middle.
Got his man, touchdown!
(triumphant music)
- Well, my priorities
in life are, number one,
my faith in God.
Number two, my family and my
relationships with my family.
Number three is academics,
and number four is football.
If those get jumbled around and
you get the wrong one first,
you can have a lot of problems.
For me, you know, trying to stay grounded,
that's the best way to do
it is have your priorities
and try to live by them.
- [Sportscaster] On first down.
- [Sportscaster] Tebow, with time.
Throwing over the middle, wide open!
To the five, touchdown!
(crowd cheering)
- [Sportscaster] Tebow, with
the carry, patient running.
Tebow's got to fight
himself into the end zone
and Tebow has a Denver touchdown.
(triumphant music)
- [Sportscaster] The
third and long, Tebow.
To Decker, he's got it!
Touchdown Denver!
- I want it to stay in our
hearts and keep hurting,
because this would motivate me personally,
and I believe everybody else,
coaches and the rest of the players,
to never let something
like this happen again.
Especially when we feel
we're better than a team
and don't play up to our ability.
And I just want to say one thing
to the fans and everybody in Gator Nation.
I'm sorry, extremely sorry.
You know, we're hoping
for an undefeated season,
that was my goal, something
before has never done here.
But I promise you one thing.
A lot of good will come out of this.
You have never seen any
player in the entire country
play as hard as I will play
the rest of the season.
And you never seen someone
push the rest of the team
as hard as I will push everybody
the rest of the season.
And you never seen a team play harder
than we will the rest of the season.
God bless.
(dramatic music)
- [Sportscaster] Pump fake, Tebow throws!
Touchdown Broncos!
Eric Decker wide open,
and Tebow will strike.
- You weren't created by a mediocre God.
You weren't created to be mediocre.
You were created for good works
which he claimed beforehand.
You were created to do amazing things
and sometimes we just got
to realize our potential.
We got to realize that we were
created by an awesome God.
We were created to amazing things.
And if sometimes we
just had the confidence
that we were created to
do something special,
then go do something special.
But you have to believe in yourself.
You have to believe that you are gifted
for such a time as this.
You have to believe that
you have the talent.
you can make the choice
every single day to wake up, to love it,
to be passionate about it and sacrifice.
(lively music)
- [Sportscaster] Tebow on the play clock,
and play fake, looking around.
Shake off tacklers, and
got a big play from Tebow!
And it's inside the 10.
And that is a touchdown!
For Denver!
(upbeat music)
- As a football player and as an athlete
I'm someone who goes extremely hard
and so I need to train extremely hard
and constantly keep going.
I don't want a lot of rest because I want
to be able to go, go, go in the games.
When other teams and
other players get tired
I want to be able to be
at my peak and keep going.
And so this is a workout where
you're going to put your body
under fatigue but you're
going to be able to keep going
and that's a lot how I play.
- He loves to train hard.
The harder the workout is,
it elevates him through the workout.
- As a team, as a
player, I like being able
to wear people down.
Where I feel like I have an
advantage in the 4th quarter,
and the 2nd half.
And that's how I like to train,
is to be able to feel like I have an edge,
and I feel like that is my edge,
and so I like to train that way.
(lively music)
You know, whatever you're doing,
put everything into it, put
your whole heart into it
and you're going to get
something out of it.
So if you really want to become your best,
push yourself in whatever you're doing
as hard as you possibly can
and you will find results.
It's not always about the workout,
it's about the work ethic.
And knowing you have the work ethic,
then you can find the right
workout to fit your body
and fit what you're trying to accomplish.
(electronic music)
- Push!
- [Man] What's he doing?
- [Man] He's been
pushing like since seven.
- [Man] Keep pushing that!
- [Man] Yes!
(Tim groaning)
- [Man] Game on!
- See what we need to do
to get a picture of this.
(music drowning out speaker)
- [Woman] I'm so excited to see you!
- You all have a blessed day.
(electronic music)
- [Man] Go! Go!
- [Man] Push! Go!
Already up to 10 miles an hour.
- [Man] Back there at that point.
- [Man] Going to need a ride?
- [Man] Go on and get a ride there, boy.
(electronic music)
- My philosophy since I was a little boy
is hard work beats talent, when
talent doesn't work as hard.
I think the biggest example
is just how I go about
living every day and honestly practicing.
And when people say, why
do you practice so hard?
Or, why do you run every sprint so hard?
You don't have to do it,
you're in good enough shape.
Well it's not just because I'm doing it
to get in better shape or
I'm doing it to be a leader.
No I'm doing it because
everything I do I want to,
you know, set the mark that
this is how you know, I do it.
Because I do all things
for the glory of God.
I do everything as hard
as I can because I do want
to set a good example.
Because I do want to be a good leader.
Because I do want to be in shape.
Because I do want to
be the hardest worker.
But more than anything,
because when I do something,
I want to be the best
that I possibly can at it.
Get in here!
Hey!
We got 30 minutes to worry
about the rest of our lives!
30 minutes for the rest of our lives!
There's nowhere better than first now!
It ain't happening!
We get the ball, I promise you one thing.
We're going to hit somebody,
and we're taking it
downfield for a touchdown.
I guarantee you that!
- [Player] It's guaranteed.
- Look at me!
Look at me!
We've got 30 minutes for
the rest of our lives!
Let's go!
- Let's go!
Hey, hey, hey!
(shouting)
Put your heart on the table.
(uplifting music)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Hector Sanchez asked me to.
Also if you want to nominate
someone for the next top 10 video
please check the description
for a link to a video
where you can vote for people
and put in your suggestions as well.
I'd love to know, what did
you take from this video?
What was the most important
lesson that you learned
that blew your mind that you're
going to immediately apply
to your life or your business somehow?
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Mike Markham
from restaurant-hr.com.
Mike, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book Your One Word.
I really appreciate the support
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(swooshing)
- I think whoever you are,
you can at least respect
that I have an opinion on it
and that I believe in something
and that I'm going to stand
up for what I believe.
And so that's something
that I'm taking pride in
is that I'm standing up
for what I believe in
and I'm showing conviction
about something.
And for me that's big.
Most people don't wake up
every single day excited
to take on life.
Excited to take on the
challenges, and ready and able
for whatever life throws at them.
No, it's they have to have a coffee.
And, you know, I got
to figure it out first
then I'm going to get excited.
Are you actually passionate
about what you do?
Are you willing to sacrifice for it?
Are you really excited about it?
Do you really love it?
'Cause I'll tell you this.
If you do, you will have such an edge.
Because people will want to be around you.
Why?
'Cause not many people live like that.
There's just not many
people who live like that.
There's not really that many people
that wake up every single day
and say, man I love life,
I'm passionate about it.
I'm ready to take it on.
I'm going to sacrifice for it.
You don't get that a lot.
But you can be that
person, do you know why?
Because it's not a gift, it's a choice.
That's a choice.
You wake up every day, and you can say
today I'm waking up to get better.
I'm not waking up to get by.
Today I'm waking up because I love it,
I'm excited about it,
I'm passionate about it,
I'm willing to sacrifice today.
I'm willing to go all-in today.
The way that I have to train
for baseball is different
than I did for so many years for football,
and taking 11, 12 years off of baseball,
of off baseball, and playing football
I definitely have to play
a little bit of catch-up.
But it's also fun when I'm
getting to live out two dreams.
- I think we all think if
you're not a certain age
that you have to give
up on certain dreams,
or you can't try something
new or change your direction.
That's another great lesson.
- Absolutely.
And then also a thing is people
do something based on the
chances they have of succeeding.
Since when were dreams
based on the chances?
Dreams are based on something
that's placed in your heart.
- That's right.
- And it's not based on the
chances of succeeding, it's going
out and living everyday.
- You have to have vision.
That's right.